we're all in search of the apex and the
other side of the mountain but we are
still headed up headed up the mountain
number of people tested last night was a
near-record amount we tested over 18,000
people with testing more people than any
state in the country and I'm very proud
of that more per capita than China and
South Korea total number of people
tested 200,000 population of 19 million
it's not going to give you a random
sample but it's been helping us track
down the positive cases number of
positive cases nine thousand two hundred
ninety-eight total cases seventy five
thousand cases you see the predominance
in New York City then Westchester the
Nassau and Suffolk then Rockland so you
can see it's it's that area of density
and it spreads out from that area of
density the march of coronavirus of
course the state of New York continues
we're down to just two counties that
don't have a case the overall numbers
seventy five thousand have tested
positive ten thousand people in our
hospitals 2700 ICU patients good news
forty-nine hundred almost five thousand
people discharged that's up 771 so
people come in they get treated they go
home excuse me
New York is at seventy-five thousand
cases next data sixteen thousand
California is at seven thousand so you
can see New York is a magnitude of
difference more than any other state
1,550 deaths that's up from twelve
hundred and eighteen yesterday again
we're studying the charts we're trying
to study the data follow the data the
data it data is uneven it bounces
numbers off and bounce in any model
there are variables in this model the
hospitals are reporting it so what every
Hospital reported that day were they
busy
are they combining a couple of days in
one it's an imperfect reporting
mechanism but you see the basic line is
still up what the statisticians will
tell you is you basically draw the
straight line that the columns indicate
and you see that we're still going up
which is what we see on the overall
trajectory that was still going up
number of intubations was down not much
but it was down and that's a good sign
you also see the number of discharges
going up and that's consistent the
longer people are in they either get
treated and leave or they get put on a
ventilator and the longer you're on a
ventilator the less likelihood you will
come off the ventilator
that is the blunt truth of this
situation we have two missions overall
that we are pursuing one is the
frontline of this battle is our hospital
system that's what this is going to come
down to the second is social
responsibility stay at home don't get
infected in the first place
don't get infected in the first place
because it goes back to you're creating
a burden on our healthcare system that
our healthcare system cannot handle
we're talking about exceeding the
capacity of our hospital system by some
estimates two times so what does this
come down to besides all the other
issues it comes down to not overwhelming
the hospital system because those people
who need acute care may not be able to
get the acute care so it's all about the
hospital system that is the frontline
what we're doing is we are following the
mathematical projections of the experts
we're speaking to all the healthcare
professionals or the healthcare
Reiter's World Health Organization
National Institute of Health dr. Fauci
CDC FDA the whole alphabet soup of
health care experts and the
mathematicians who then have different
models and we talked to about five
different models and we compared the
models and we try to find the median
through the models that's how we plan
everything follow the data follow the
science people ask me what do you think
what do you think I don't think about
this what do I know I'm not an expert
I'm not opening
I talk to experts and I follow people
who know but for the hospitals procure
equipment identify the beds support the
staff that's what it's been all about of
those priorities number one is support
the staff they are the frontline and
they need relief they are physically
exhausted even more they are emotionally
exhausted this is unlike other disasters
hurricanes earthquakes floods they
happen they're fast they're over you
start rebuilding this is different this
is ongoing and the duration itself is
debilitating and exhausting and
depressing I'm speaking to health care
professionals who say look more than
physically tired I'm just emotionally
tired seeing the pain seeing the death
that they're dealing with every day in
general I am tired of being behind this
virus we've been behind this virus from
day one the virus was in China we knew
it was in China unless we assume there's
some immune system variation with Asian
people it was coming here and we have
been behind it from day one since it got
here and we've been playing catch-up
you don't win playing catch-up we have
to get ahead of it
the second rule is never underestimate
your opponent and we underestimated this
virus it's more powerful it's more
dangerous than we expected and the third
point is planned forward get ahead of it
get ahead of it fight the fight today
yes but anticipate the next battle and
plan for the next battle and the main
battle is at the apex we're still going
up the mountain the main battle is on
the top of the mountain that's where the
main battle is going to be the apex of
the curve and then we come down the
other side of the mountain
we are planning now for the battle at
the top of the mountain that's what we
are doing
get a staffing plan ready now for the
battle at the top of the mountain
equipment stockpile
now we're gathering equipment that we
don't need today because today is not
the day of the battle the battle is when
we hit the apex depending on who you
believe 14 days to 30 days from today
and also we need a social acceptance of
the time expectation we're all anxious
we're all tired we're all fatigued it's
been all bad news for a long time our
whole lifestyle has been disrupted
everybody wants to know one thing when
is it over
nobody knows well president said by
Easter this one said by this nobody
knows you can have a hypothesis you can
have in the projection you can have an
opinion but nobody knows but I can say
this it is not going to be soon if our
apex is 14 to 21 days that's our apex
you then have to come down the other
side of the mountain once you hit the
apex so calibrate yourself and your
expectations so you're not disappointed
every morning you get up yesterday we
met with the entire State House
system dr. Zucker and our team first
time they were all in one place and we
said to the hospital system look what I
just said to you we're dealing with a
war we're dealing with a war we've never
dealt with before we need a totally
different mindset and organizational
transformation we can't do business the
way we have always done business we need
an unprecedented sense of cooperation of
flexibility communication and speed and
that's what we talked through yesterday
and we have to do it now the healthcare
system is one of those balkanized
systems it's like our state education
system it's like our criminal justice
system it's in place it's fragmented
they have their own identities their own
associations
it's regionally organized that all has
to change we don't have the ability to
meet the capacity of our healthcare
system as an entirety that assumes the
health care system is working as an
entirety that's not how the health care
system is organized now we have New York
City hospitals and then we have Long
Island hospitals and then we have
Westchester hospitals and then we have
upstate hospitals that has to go even in
New York City you have two basic
hospital systems in New York City you
have the private hospitals voluntary
hospitals about 160 of them which are
some of the finest healthcare
institutions in the United States of
America you know this is Mount Sinai
Columbia Presbyterian etc some of their
members are also upstate but they're the
large private institutions Greater New
York Hospital Association can rescue
runs that Association of 160 you then
have in New York City the public
hospitals the New York City Health and
Hospitals corporation they are 11 public
hospitals they are
a universe and then you have the private
hospitals as a separate universe the 11
public hospitals are the hospitals that
in many ways have always been under
greater stress in greater need we have
to get those two systems the private
system and the public system in New York
City working together in a way they
never did before
the distinction of private public that
has to go out the window
we are one health care system on top of
that it can't be the downstate hospitals
and the Upstate hospitals and the Long
Island hospitals when we talk about
capacity of beds when I say we now have
75,000 beds
that's a statewide number that means
those beds have to be available to the
people in New York City or Nassau even
if those beds are up in Albany so
combining that whole system and you're
no longer just the western New York
hospitals or the central New York
hospitals it's one coordinated system
it's much easier said than done but we
have to do it on top of that you have to
overlay the new federal beds that came
in that are an entirely new component we
have Javits Center 2500 beds we have the
USNS comfort of 1,000 beds we're
planning other federal facilities these
all have to be coordinated on top of the
existing hospital network so you see the
organizational situation that we're
dealing with and let's be honest and
let's learn from the past we know where
we have to focus we know where we're
going to have problems in the next
hospitals because the hospitals that
have the least capacity that have
already been stressed are the hospitals
that are not going to be able to handle
the additional load
that is a fact you know which hospitals
were struggling we do reports all the
time
about the financial capacity of
hospitals and and what hospitals are in
stronger versus weaker position the
hospitals that are in a weaker position
are the hospitals that are going to
suffer when they then carry an added
burden that was Elmhurst Hospital it
happened to be a public hospital it
happened to be a public hospital in a
place of density it happened to get
overwhelmed and that's what then you saw
the burden on the staff
you saw the emotion you sure saw the
stress that can't happen and that's what
we talked about yesterday and people
said well Elmhurst isn't my
responsibility Elmhurst is a public
hospital the city runs it I don't run it
it's New York City it's not a private
hospital I don't care which link breaks
in the chain the chain is still broken
it doesn't matter which hospital which
link any link breaks the chain breaks
the healthcare system is a chain it
breaks anywhere it breaks everywhere
that has to be our mentality we laid out
a full plan on how to do facility
development how to move people among
hospitals so nobody gets overloaded
shifting patients shifting staff
shifting supplies none of us have enough
supplies okay then let's pull our
supplies and let's put them out to the
people who need them
and just because one Hospital happened
to have found a vendor from China who
delivered five million masks let's share
those masks and we talked about that
yesterday we also talked again at length
about
ventilators which is everybody knows is
a key piece of equipment identity
identifying all the bent l's ventilators
in the state who has them who has them
in a stockpile who ordered them who
expects them to come in and we'll have
one stock pile of ventilators that we
can distribute for everyone who needs
them we also talked about splitting of
ventilators because that's a technology
that does exist it's been used before
it's not ideal you take one ventilator
and it's used for two patients the
federal government is a partner in this
obviously I spoke to the president again
yesterday about this situation I spoke
to the vice president I spoke to Jared
Kushner the White House has been very
helpful we have to get the federal
agencies on the ground to understand how
this operates especially FEMA because we
have to be coordinated and people have
to know what they're doing and this is
no time for anyone to be learning on the
job and we're going to be working
through that today PPE same thing we
want to know what everybody has one
stockpile we'll distribute it fairly
testing how do we get out when does this
end this ends when we get a fast-track
test an at-home test a 15-minute test
and people can then find out when they
can go back to work because they're
negative we're working on additional
testing as I said the Department of
Health has a new test but that's when
this ends we're also working on the new
medications we're leading the country
and many of those developments we have
saliva testing now we're working on the
antibody testing and we're working on
the plasma testing at the same time we
put together a central coordinating team
it's going to be led by the Department
of Health
West Chester sonic greater New York is
on it Haney's is on at New York City's
on it Long Island is on it
if the federal government is going to
participate they have to be part of this
team because we have to know what we're
doing and I don't want FEMA coming in
and blowing the coordination of what
everyone is trying to do the
coordinating team is going to organize
upstate downstate transfers set patient
loads for hospitals right so if one
Hospital gets up near a overload
capacity let's call it those hospitals
start to send patients to other
hospitals before they get up to their
max within the New York City public
hospital system within the Greater New
York private system and then among the
different systems so different mentality
but we have to do it we said two
missions one was hospitals second was
individual responsibility individual
responsibility is about discipline it's
about selflessness and it's about being
informed the basic point to stay at home
the point to stay at home I know it's
hard to stay at home and I know everyone
thinks you know I can go out and I can
be smart and I won't get infected
because it's me
I'm a superhero it's not going to be me
that is not true
and it's not just about you so that's
just about your health and your life
that you're playing with here my friend
you can infect other people so I've been
trying to communicate this many
different ways for many days we still
see people coming out who don't need to
be out even for essential workers people
have to be careful and again I've been
trying to communicate that everyone
everyone is subject to this virus it is
the great equalizer I don't care
how smart how rich how powerful you
think you are I don't care how young how
old this virus is the great equalizer my
brother Chris is positive for
coronavirus found out this morning the
now he is going to be fine
he's young in good shape strong not as
strong as he thinks but he will be fine
but there's a lesson in this
he's an essential worker a member of the
press so he's been out there if you go
out there the chance that you get
infected is very high I spoke to him
this morning and he's going to be
quarantined in his basement at home he's
just worried about his daughter and his
kids that he hopes he didn't get them
infected you don't really know Chris you
know you see Chris he has a show on
night 9 o'clock on CNN but you just see
one dimension right you see a person in
his job and in his job he's combative
and he's argumentative and he's pushing
people but that's his job that's really
not who he is he's a really sweet
beautiful guy and it's my best friend my
father was always working so it was
always just me and Chris and he's a
lawyer also Chris he's a lawyer because
growing up the decision point came to
what do you want to do after college and
my father was a very strong personality
and my father basically suggested
forcefully to Chris that he should be a
lawyer it was a different time in a
different place you know now my
daughter's Cara who's here and they all
follow their individuals
this is their destiny which is right if
you had said to my father I want to
follow my individual star he would say
you you can follow your individual star
right out that door
instead so Chris went to law school but
he never really had a desire to practice
law he calls me when he's about 26 is
that a law firm and he said you know I
don't want to be a lawyer I said yeah I
know but you are now a lawyer you are he
said yeah but I don't want to be a
lawyer I said what do you want to be he
said I want to be a journalist I said
you want to be a journalist it says too
late
you're a lawyer you have to pay law
school bills
you didn't go to journalism school it's
too late no no I think I can do it and
God blessing me quit the law firm went
to work for Fox TV which is all separate
conversation in the house and then
worked his way up he's at CNN he does a
beautiful job but a sweet guy and I was
quarantined in the basement but it's
funny except she says to me even the
dogs won't come downstairs he says but
he is concerned about his wife and his
kids but the reason I raised it is he's
smart he social distancing yes but you
wind up exposing yourself people wind up
exposing you and then they find out
they're positive a couple of days later
and I had a situation with Christopher
two weeks ago that I even mentioned my
mother was at his house and I said that
is a mistake now my mother is in a
different situation she's she's older
and she's healthy but I said you can't
have mom at the house and he said no no
no mom is lonely she wants to be at the
house I feel bad she's cooped up in the
apartment I said yeah I feel better ease
cooped up in the apartment too but you
bring her to your house you expose her
to a lot of things you have the kids
there you have your wife there you're
coming and going your wife is coming in
going and you could expose mom to the
virus and love is sometimes a little
needs to be a little smarter than just
reactive and we had a whole discussion
and truth now he's informed I'm informed
was that dangerous was that not
dangerous so I went back to dr. Zucker I
said look we have to tell people what
are the rules how does this work
that's when I came up with Matilda's law
and I said I named it for my mother and
it was very clear about people who are
older and what they should be exposed to
my brother that was two weeks ago if my
brother still had my mother at his house
again out of love and comfort and my
mother wanted to be at the house anyway
by the way she didn't want to be sitting
at home in an apartment so she would
have been doing what she wanted to do he
would have been doing what he wanted to
do it would have seemed great and
harmless but now we'd have a much
different situation because if he was
exposed
chances are she may very well have been
exposed and then we would be looking at
a different situation than just my
brother sitting in his basement for two
months two weeks so think about that
right my brother smart he was acting out
of love luckily we caught it early
enough but it's my family it's your
family it's all of our families and this
virus is that insidious and we have to
keep that in mind keep in mind Matilda's
law remember who is vulnerable here and
protect them you want to go out and act
stupid for yourself that's one thing but
your stupid actions don't just affect
you you come home you can affect infect
someone else
and you can cause a serious illness or
even death for them by your actions and
people have to really get this and
internalize it because it can happen to
anyone
two weeks with my mother and Christopher
today is a very different situation last
point there was nothing that I have said
different since I started these
briefings and there's nothing that we
have learned that is different since
I've started these briefings we know
what to do we just have to do it it is
individual discipline to stay at home
that's what it is it's discipline no
social distancing it's discipline well
I'm bored I know I'm bored it's
discipline making this healthcare system
work that's government skill that's
government performance that's saying to
that health care system I don't care how
it worked yesterday and okay whose turf
this is I don't care whose ego was
involved I'm sorry we have to find a way
to work a better way it's a time to say
to that federal government and to FEMA
and HHS you have to learn how to do your
job and you have to learn how to do it
quickly because time is not our friend
it's about a social stamina this is not
one week two weeks three weeks four
weeks five weeks six weeks okay this is
not going to be an Easter surprise
understand that and have the stamina to
deal with it and it's unity
let's help one another New York needs
help now yesterday yesterday I asked for
health care workers from across the
country to come here because we need
help we will pay you and more
importantly we will return the favor
this is going to be a rolling wave
across the country New York
then it'll be Detroit then it'll be New
Orleans then it will be
California if we were smart as a nation
come help us in New York get the
equipment get the training get the
experience and then let's all go help
the next place and then the next place
and then the next place that would be a
smart national way of doing this and
showing that unity and unity meaning
we're not I know this is a political
year and everybody everything is a
political backdrop and Democrats want to
criticize Republicans Republicans want
to criticize that Democrats not now not
now there are no red states there are no
blue states the virus doesn't attack and
kill red Americans or blue Americans it
attacks all Americans and keep that in
mind because there is there is a
unifying wisdom and that any questions
let's do on topic questions first if
anyone has any questions on local issues
we'll do that afterwards
[Music]
yeah well let's remember what we said we
have now a few days ago we put out a
question is are all healthcare workers
working the problem is health care
workers are working too much they're
overstressed they're working too many
shifts they're afraid to go home they
may bring the virus home they're under
immense physical and emotional stress we
put out a request a couple of days ago
to ask retirees to come forward we have
now about 78,000 people who said that
they would help
god bless the state of New York and God
bless you mannered we now are working
with the hospitals and we did this in
the meeting yesterday also sorting those
78,000 people by region and by expertise
across the state and we have a portal
that Jim or Howard can explain because
we then have to link them up with a
hospital right
you don't need we have the 78 that pool
of 78,000 you then have to coordinate
that with the hospital in that region
with those skills and that's what we're
doing now Jim you wanted right so today
the portal will be launched in live the
78,000 or so there were we have to do
some pre checking so we check for
licenses discipline and those people who
didn't have a licensure have
disciplinary issues were taken out so
the hospitals could more easily access
the workforce as the governor said
they're broken down by region by
discipline and now they can go in and
what we're trying to do is prioritize
the availability of the portal to the
hospitals that need of the most right
now who have that needs some extra help
in the field but we're working very
closely with the entire system like the
governor said to make sure we're linking
up those new health care workers to
those new to facilities so it will be
live today
it's everyone everyone so what we're
trying to do is prioritize the in-state
workers which we have by region so we
know the potential health care workers
in every region of the state where they
are with their statuses we want to get
those people in first because they're
here in New York we want to prioritize
actually the New York Regional downstate
regional employees because we know that
they're closer to those facilities that
are in need now and we're gonna need the
Upstate employees potentially later and
then we have the out-of-state employees
that are potentially we're trying to
keep those folks close to so looking at
the folks from New Jersey looking at the
folks from kinetic and other places that
where they don't have to travel from
long distances we are looking at age and
we're going through a back where we have
about 175 people doing backgrounds on
every person who comes into the portal
and the hospitals we're working with as
well will also do their own checks to
make sure the persons up to it so if
they may not be up to one job they may I
should be up to another job so we're
making sure we have some cross
coordination there as well and some of
the hospitals could potentially have
some of these folks in needed areas by
Thursday new directions as to when the
apex might hit in New York City and the
state as a whole when does the new apex
hit that is the $64,000 question we have
literally five models that we look at
it's true to say almost no two are the
same the range on the apex is somewhere
between let's say 7 to 21 days if you
look at all 5 it's 7 to 21 days from now
and let's just I say this doesn't mean
no good what is it 7 to 21 the range is
is too broad do I have 7 or do I have 3
weeks there's all sorts of variables
that they're looking at you know on one
hand you would think they would be able
to tell because you have the China model
you have the South Korea data etc but
then you have variables here how
effective is the social
how many people are actually staying
home how does the density relate so
there are variables but it goes from the
apex estimate seven to twenty one that's
not the only estimate that varies
they then vary on how many beds you
would need right we have 53,000 beds
statewide if we operate it as a state we
mandated 50% more beds so now we're up
to 75,000 beds all of them say you need
more than the 75,000 and the high
estimate is 140,000 the ventilator
estimate among those projections goes
from 10 to 40,000 of those right Jim do
you remember Howard on most average
actually we'll let you put in a receiver
into somebody's hospitals if they don't
meet that 50% threshold or even go above
that do you foresee having to do that
and what would that allow you and dr.
Zucker to do the hospitals have been
cooperative the question is we have the
ability to point the receiver if a
hospital is not being cooperative the
hospitals have been cooperative we put
out that rule that you have to have to
wait at 50% capacity they all added 50%
capacity
they've all responded we're sending out
a rule today that says I want to know
your stock what you haven't stock what
your stockpile is what your inventory is
because we really need to share you know
nobody has enough so like everybody put
everything into the middle in a pot and
then we'll distribute it we're doing
that it's not it's not Joe going to be
as much they're not listening it's going
to be their capacity level right you
have a stake downstate New York you have
about 170 hospitals
if we sat here two months ago we could
have graded almost all 170 hospitals and
you would have had some stronger and
some weaker as a general rule the public
hospitals would have been on the weaker
spectrum let's financing etcetera
history of being more troubled you now
put weight on all 170 even if you put
the equal amount of weight on all 170
you're gonna see a different reaction in
the hospital depending on the underlying
strength of that hospital you put a
differentiated weight but you happen to
be in Brooklyn and that happens to be
more density in Brooklyn and that
hospital gets more weight you'd get a
different variable but in general what
you're going to see is the hospitals
that were stressed can't take the stress
right it's not even a medical concept
the worst with personalities - the
personalities who were having trouble
dealing with stress are having more
trouble dealing with this dress so the
health and hospital corporations what I
said - which are the public hospitals I
said - the private hospitals you have to
help them and we have to watch when they
get up near capacity transfer patients
Elmhurst got up to capacity you had
other public hospitals that have had
open beds we have to get better and
faster at transferring patients to other
facilities right a perfect system
everybody's at 51% everybody's at 60%
everybody's at 80% not some people are
at 40% and some people are at 110
percent that's not the way the system is
organized right now they all talk you
know they all have but they're different
chiefdoms that
different systems and that you know you
almost have to shock the system into
actually saying okay we're really going
to operate as one yes but look no
hospitals going to say I want to be over
capacity
it's just they didn't have the
cooperation or the system to call
someone up and say you know I'm drowning
I need to have somebody else accept 150
patients and that's going to have to
have to be managed into the system this
is something we never did before as I
run because we never we've never been
here you know
normally you are beds that are hospitals
fighting for patients because patients
are revenue right so you never had a
situation where they said I'm gonna send
you patients they wanted the patients
they wanted the revenues so this is a
much different situation I'm sorry no no
first first we have levels of sort of
triage first we're gonna try to bring up
state staff down to New York state
hospitals it's one of the requests we're
going to make today
you have upstate hospitals that are
nowhere near capacity send your staff
down to New York City hospitals worse
step you're over capacity in all New
York City hospitals you've redistributed
the load you're still over capacity then
send people to the upstate hospital is
that right Howard
it would all be voluntary
well we're all paying the cost right the
hospitals are paying the cost the state
is paying the cost and I said to them
look frankly we'll figure out the cost
because this is about saving lives and
I'm not gonna get you know who pays the
bill should not determine whether or not
people live or die so I said do whatever
we have to do to save lives and then
we'll figure out the bill afterwards I
said I needed 30,000 well that's an
interesting question we have ordered
17,000 from China yes that we would pay
for roughly $25,000 each by the way
anyone who says oh maybe the you don't
need that many ventilators you're saying
30,000 ventilators you don't need that
many you don't really believe you need
that many you know how you know I really
really believe that number because we
are paying twenty five thousand dollars
per ventilator and we are broke and the
last thing I want to do is buy a single
ventilator that I don't need the
complexity with ventilators is we
ordered 17,000 from China
so did California so that Illinois so
did the federal government so did Italy
and what's happening is China the orders
into China are very slow in coming out
exactly how and why we're not sure it's
just that they're they have such a
tremendous demand of the 17,000 we only
have a firm expectation on 2,500 is that
right Kara yes
only have a firm expectation of 2500
they're supposed to come in over the
next two weeks
yes no the ventilator capacity increases
2500 and ICU bed in this situation is
essentially and I a bed with oxygen and
a ventilator but you can't have an ICU
bed in this situation without a
ventilator well if it's depends if it's
six weeks or 21 days right that's what
we're dealing with and you can't
accelerate the orders anymore from China
when you go back to when we go back into
a retro specular and I don't want to do
it now but look at the bizarre situation
we wind up in every state does its own
purchasing so new yorkers purchase in
california's purchasing illinois is
purchasing we're all trying to buy the
same commodity literally the same exact
item so you have 50 states competing to
buy the same item we all wind up bidding
up each other and competing against each
other where you now literally will have
a company call you up and say will
California just outbid you it's like
being on eBay with 50 other states
bidding on a ventilator and you see the
bid go up because California bid
Illinois bid Florida bid New York bids
California rebates
that's literally what we're doing I mean
how inefficient and then FEMA gets
involved and FEMA starts bidding and now
FEMA is bidding on top of the 50 so FEMA
is driving up the price what sense does
this make the federal government FEMA
should have been the purchasing agent
buy everything
and then allocated by need to the states
why would you create a situation where
the 50 states are competing with each
other and then the federal government to
FEMA comes in and competes with the rest
of it non coronavirus emergencies
factored into these plans to better
coordinate the health care system
presumably with first responders getting
overwhelmed heart attacks
oh look Zack this is we're learning
lessons you know necessity is the mother
of invention we're learning things here
that it's not that we're learning things
here
anyone could have told you a lot of
these things right the situation I just
explained with purchasing did you really
have to learn that 50 states shouldn't
compete against 50 states and then FEMA
shouldn't come in late and then compete
with 50 states you know it's not like
you had to go to the Harvard Kennedy
School to learn this right should you
really have a hospital system in New
York State where you have private
hospitals you have these struggling
public hospitals there's two separate
systems the upstate are separate Long
Island is separate shouldn't you have
planned a comprehensive system yes but
the commercial barriers to that the
political barriers to that were so
intense that if you didn't have a
disaster an emergency you couldn't break
through them conversation I had with
these hospital leaders yesterday in that
room if it was not for the coronavirus I
would have never made it out of that
room I mean what I was saying was so
antithetical to the foundation of the
business of health care in this state
which by the way is a multi
multi-billion dollar business it's right
it was common sense but sometimes you
need the emergency to force
change that would be very very difficult
otherwise their specific efforts to
shore up the capacity of the healthcare
system to handle non coronavirus related
emergencies we the healthcare systems
working on all those other areas as well
and and regularly pretty much every day
I've spoken to doctors and nurses who
are working on the front lines and all
of those other patients whether the
person with a heart attack the person
with the stroke the system has continued
to move foe is stressed as the governor
has said the system is stressed but the
patients are cared for those other
emergencies are getting cared for as
well just put a strain on the system if
I said to you
look I know normally you write for your
outlet and then there are other outlets
but we have a situation and you're going
to write and you have to give it to all
the other outlets what you write is no
longer just for your publication you
have to give it to all the other outlets
because we don't have ten people who can
come you have to write for everybody
else if I said that in the normal course
of business forget it if it was an
emergency
and you were the only reporter there
then you would do it and that's true in
so many different situations you know
you're violating basic commercial rules
here and business rules and practices
and I'm a local government and I'm in
charge and you know to override all that
garbage you really need extraordinary
times
you know questions about when the next
hot spot would get the ventilators
JB Pritzker you give governor Pritzker
he's a good man he's a good friend of
mine it does a beautiful job you have a
he's right you'll have curbs right you
have a New York curve you'll have an
Illinois curve you'll have a New Orleans
curve how do you know the New York curve
is going to end before the Illinois
curve piece you don't you don't for sure
you know basically there's gonna be a
spatial sequential factor but you don't
know that we're going to be effectively
done before Illinois ramps up so it
can't be literally New York has all the
equipment Illinois has none and then we
run to Illinois with the equipment it
can't be that literal but essentially it
would work right and the alternative is
also true not everybody should have to
buy everything once we get through this
and we have whatever we wind up with
15,000 ventilators and 15,000 ventilator
splitters and 1,100 by paps you know if
we can help someone else
let's help somebody else
New York City police officer is called
in sick this morning are you worried
about staffing of law enforcement in New
York City and conversely would you
consider sending State Police to help
with that oh I'm worried about staffing
yes my word yes you're gonna see it with
health care workers you're gonna see it
with for all first responders look it's
back to my brother Chris yeah if you are
out there your chance of getting
infected is very high yes and then we'll
do whatever we need to back Phil if we
need State Police I would do that what's
happening Nick is it is almost
impossible to buy a ventilator to the
extent anyone is successful in buying
ventilators FEMA basically came in and
is now capturing the market because the
ventilators are coming out of China and
FEMA basically big-footed the states in
China so to the extent anyone is buying
it it's FEMA and that's why the federal
distribution is going to be so important
because they are the only ones I can't
buy a ventilator I can't buy a
ventilator
whatever we're willing to pay I can't
buy a ventilator so it really comes down
to how the federal government
distributes it and that's why it's so
important
let's do someone who hasn't asked the
question when the state runs out of
ventilators where do I decide to gets
him
well first I don't even want to think
about that consequence I want to do
everything I can to have as many
ventilators as we'll need seven to 21
days no there's no protocol we're
working to get as many ventilators and
we have now a number of options we have
we're looking at all the ventilators all
of course the state we are then
redeploying anesthesia machines as
ventilators by changing event within
doing this ventilator splitting which
effectively turns one ventilator into
two by literally running two tubes we're
using northwell developed an idea to use
a BiPAP machine we've ordered 7,000 of
those so we're still in it we're
creative and we're working and figuring
it out and I still am hopeful that at
the end of the day we have what we need
I plan on signing a budget do you know
candy Rob can the state of employees
when we pass a budget this stadium if we
pass a budget on time the state
employees get paid right yeah the
Comptroller currently has the legal
authority to make the payments now right
the payments that are due tomorrow and
today those are actually for payroll
from two weeks ago so the controller
presently has the authority they have a
technical issue with their computer
system that they need to deal with but
they have the authority to make those
payments to day has nothing to do with
when the budget is passed the budget is
always passed on the 31st or the first
of each year so that is the routes of
controller's office issue
yes that's right they have they have
sufficient appropriation authority to
make those payments presently no there's
nothing to do without the pay period
fell they presently have the authority
to do it they presently have full legal
authority and appropriation authority to
make the payments never not paid the
state employees even when the budget was
late yes so what are your questions so
what's the no update see how easy it is
either come in or it's not coming we are
where we are you know the the numbers of
what the numbers are the numbers don't
lie the numbers leave you few
alternatives federal government says
they're going to provide funding if they
provide the funding then the next few
months we should have some additional
money but am I going to say to the
people of the state I believe the
federal government is going to deliver
money to the state government heard it
before and it didn't happen so I'm not
going to count on money that we don't
have especially when the political
process is the process that's supposed
to deliver the money
were you well it's also it's interesting
because it's all basically contingent we
have the budget we do a budget on the
projections we now have if we get more
funding we increase the allocations if
we don't get more funding we reduce the
allocations that's basically what the
budget says right it's it's it's
essentially honest and transparent in a
way I'm starting the year I'm earning
$15,000 a year I don't know what I can
pay you because I don't know what I'll
be earning as we go through the year the
boss tells me he's gonna give me a raise
I don't know if I should believe him or
not
some people say there's going to be a
cut
I don't really know so here's the budget
I'm making fifteen thousand dollars if I
get a raise I will give you the raise
quarterly as I get it if I get cut I
will give you less quarterly as I get
cut that's all you can do let them come
and cut a budget how free you think do
you really believe that they want to
come back here and cut the budget I'd
give them total authority to cut the
budget come back to me to cut the budget
it is not it is not working as smoothly
as I would like to see it
it's compounding people stress you're
you're unemployed you're trying to get
on some dawn website you can't get
through the website we have companies
working on it we have literally hundreds
of people working on it I apologize for
the pain it is must be infuriating to
deal with I am Telling You we have every
technology
camping company working on it we're
spending a lot of money the site is so
deluge that it keeps crashing because
you literally have hundreds of thousands
of people at any time trying to get on
the site and it continues to crash do
you have any update on a few rough just
the numbers we usually get 50,000 calls
a week or look we got 1.2 million calls
yesterday and 7.8 million calls last
week so that's just the order of
magnitude but as the governor said we
all of resources devoted to improving
the system one point one point two
million calls well you don't know unless
you in a week yesterday alone 1.2
million last week over seven million so
that's the order of magnitude and that's
the volume that we're dealing with but
as the governor said we're putting all
the resources in to improve the system
and be responsible 23 guards and 14
inmates at state prisons who are
positive for Corona
but Doc's is not saying where are those
guards or where those inmates are is
there a reason for that that would seem
to be counter to public safety no I've
never heard that Jesse
I'll check I just it's the first I've
heard of us anyone who sees me would
second anyone who hasn't asked the
question and wants to ask the question
residential areas that also extend to
businesses or restaurants that may be
renting we extended it to commercial you
did we extended it to commercial you
cannot be evicted for non-payment of
rent residential nor commercial for
three months again we picked these
integrals and you can say there's
somewhat random but you know when is it
going to end
nobody knows pick an interval so we said
three months you can't be evicted
residential or commercial for
non-payment of rent for 90 days on that
basis my daughter's have stopped paying
me rent I'm not even sure that their
finances have dropped significantly but
I think they're just taking advantage of
the non eviction order that I myself
posted and I resent it but there's
nothing I can do about it yes the person
another underlying medical condition you
know I usually don't like to give out
clinical information but I can see why
the complication of this virus would
have caused with this virus would have
caused a problem that that individual
they were they were minor put it 0 to 17
years old with a child a teenager
privacy laws that if the doctor doesn't
want to if he wants to stay in his
current occupation he has to be a little
careful
be able to get a deal on that here and
not likely what happened just too much
too much too little time the other form
we said we've been working on a bail
reform is something we've talked about
until we're blue in the face for two
years yeah well you know who covered it
so bail reform we have to get done last
question Zach but you're going to share
this what we agree that you're going to
share this reporting with all your
colleagues before you post it I love
when they lie to me renters should do
once you were 90-day moratorium on
evictions ends and they like Leo you
know several months of rents you know
unemployment is obviously we'll deal
with that when we get to about here
usually there has to be some we have to
finish the budget to tell you the size
of the budget solutions proceeding for
knowing the size of the budget finishing
the
God will determine who is to blame you
and I just deal with the reality the
senior senator will say he is in the
minority which is true the house is
controlled by Democrats
we took a pounding on both bills we did
not get our fair share in what's called
the FMF bill the Medicaid money bill and
we got the lowest percentage
reimbursement flows percentage of aid of
any state in the United States for this
last bill which was supposed to be
providing funding for Co vid but we had
the highest number of kovat cases and we
got the lowest percentage of funding so
they'll say politics
I see politics be damned in the middle
of us thank you